- Everyone, thank you
for coming, good morning.
You probably guessed, I'm Taz,
tech leader for AWS data analytics.
- And I'm Shikha Verma.
I'm the head of product for
data and analytics at AWS,
very excited to have you all here.
Let's get started, lots of content.
- Right, everyone ready?
- [Audience Member 1] Yes.
- I know it's a little early
in the morning at least for me.
Let's wake up.
(Taz giggles)
(Shikha giggles)
Okay, so, in terms of the agenda,
what we have for you today is first,
we will be level-setting what
exactly data foundation means.
Because you ask the person next to you,
you'll get a different
definition depending
on the day, on the time of the day.
So, we'll level-set what that means.
We'll in fact take it to the next level,
which is data analytics,
sorry, data foundation,
what it means for data analytics
and what it means for
agentic AI applications.
We'll talk about how
you can bridge the gap
between data and AI using
the AI-ready data foundation
on AWS.
Examples of this will
include AWS MCP servers,
followed by an in-depth look
of how you can use AWS data
analytics to manage context.
We'll also talk about
event-driven architectures
where your application
may have multiple agents
and then, you will bring this all together
with the most critical
part for data and AI,
which is how do you make
your data ready for AI?
We'll talk about data governance,
we'll talk about metadata management
and that's essentially data readiness.
So, Shikha, shall we begin?
- That all sounds good theoretically,
but I think we need to root it in example
where we can show everybody
how we can actually do this live.
Don't you guys think, yeah?
So, we should use a demo to
demonstrate what we have.
Can we do that, Taz?
Can we use our own data for the AI agents?
- Your wish is my command.
I have a demo for you.
We are a travel agent company.
That's the premise of the demo.
We'll use that to showcase
how you can leverage the
data foundation on AWS
to build an agentic AI application
and get the most out of it.
All right.
- That sounds good, guys?
- Thank you.
- Let's do it.
- So, let's begin by level-setting
on what is a data foundation.
On AWS, this is essentially
for data analytics,
this is what it means when we
say data foundation, right?
This is having access to data tools
that allow you to deliver
on basic constructs of data analytics,
like data storage, data processing,
data integration, data governance.
And all of this with the price performance
and the ability to scale
as and when you need it.
This is at its very core is what we mean
by data foundation for data analytics.
And these foundations,
constructs basically,
they come together to give
you a typical data pipeline
that you see over here
with the different
components coming together
to give you an output that is
important to your business.
But what does this mean for AI?
What we are trying to say,
is when you are working on
building AI applications, right,
it doesn't actually have to mean
that you have to look for something new,
or build something new in
terms of data foundation.
You should be able to leverage
what you already have.
And that's essentially the crux
of this particular section over here.
You should be able to evolve and adapt
to build your agentic AI applications.
Because data
and data engineering are
key AI differentiators.
Even though, that might
be a backend aspect
of agentic AI applications,
it is still critical.
And here's that story in two pictures.
Shikha, what do you think?
- What do we think, guys?
Sound okay?
Like do we think data is
a differentiator for AI?
Just show of hands.
Yeah?
Pretty much everybody.
But do you guys ever say
that data engineering is
a differentiator for AI?
Anybody says that?
- I mean, we believe you
when you say data is important for AI.
(Shikha giggles)
But let's be honest,
when we talk about AI,
is data processing, data
storage, data governance,
is that top of mind?
- [Audience Member 2] Yes.
- Yeah, top of mind?
- Nice, we have a great crowd here.
And that is essentially
the point we are trying
to make over here,
which is data is critical for
a successful AI application
and needs a strong data foundation.
And it should be made up of data tools
that allow you to extend the capabilities
to build the AI application.
All right, Shikha, shall we
proceed with the next section?
- Yeah, I think you have
a good story to tell here
and I can see that our
audience is engaged.
So, folks, I'm gonna leave
you in Professor Taz's hands
for a bit, right?
He's gonna show us how this is done
and he'll show us some real
data with real AI agents.
And then I'll come back on stage
to talk about a few other things.
Go for it, Taz.
- Thank you, Shikha.
Okay, so, really quick,
an AI-ready data foundation on an AWS,
at least for businesses,
what does that mean?
Essentially, what we are
saying is it's a foundation
that lets you fuel AI innovations,
speeds up efficient delivery
with little to no impact to
your bottom line as a business.
That is a data foundation
that businesses get from AWS.
But we want to focus
on what do developers and
builders get out of this.
And that is what we will be covering
for the most of this talk.
And this image here is
actually a testament
to the AI-ready data foundation on AWS.
Really quick, any guesses
as to what this image is?
- [Audience Member 3] Project Rainier.
- Thank you.
So, yeah, this is our Project
Rainier Cluster Compute
that was recently launched,
one of the world's largest
AI compute clusters.
It uses a lot of core components
of the AI-ready data
foundation that we have on AWS.
So, for the most part of this talk,
we want to focus on how
can data personalities,
like data engineers,
data analysts, data scientists
get the most benefits
from an AI-ready data foundation.
So, we are recommending
two approaches essentially.
The first is quite fundamental.
It's actually understanding
how your data foundation constructs,
such as storage, processing, ingestion,
are influenced when you
build an AI application.
And the second is more,
it's a more prescriptive approach
about deploying the AI-ready capabilities
that the data foundation has
to accelerate your AI development.
The first approach is best understood
by looking at the evolution of AI.
Now, this has rapidly progressed
from something simple like assistance
to more complex autonomous systems.
We started with GenAI assistance
that follow predefined rules
to automate repetitive tasks.
Then, quickly, moved on to AI
agents that are goal-oriented,
capable of handling a
broader range of tasks
and adopting the changing environments.
And then, today, where we
are at, is we are moving
towards fully autonomous
multi-agent systems
that can make complex decisions.
The evolution of AI has a direct impact
on your typical data pipeline.
They also evolve when used in the context
of building AI applications.
The very first thing or one
of the very first things
that AI introduces is a need
for additional data sources.
And these are primarily in
the form of unstructured data.
Now, unstructured data
is not a new construct.
However, it is new in the sense
that it doesn't conform
to a preset data model,
it doesn't have a predefined schema.
And this is new territory
for most data personalities.
Functions like metadata
management, data governance
for unstructured data
takes a whole new meaning
and has a big influence
on things like data
processing, data integration
and data storage.
The next construct
that gets influenced is
around data processing, right?
This is an area where
you would start working
on aspects of training
or validating your data
to move data from data
warehouses or data lakes
to improve the model accuracy,
or you could be running inference
for your continued pre-training approach
for near real-world scenarios,
or managing vector data
for a RAG-based application
to provide real-time context.
And all this data processing
requires advanced forms
of data integrations and data storage.
Next, some AI applications
also incorporate techniques,
such as including human feedback
to optimize the ML models.
These applications need to
capture user input in real time
for a highly personalized user experience.
Capturing this information
in the right kind of storage
with efficient pipelines helps
with latency and accuracy.
And then finally, because an
AI application opens itself up
to a much wider variety
of data sources and users,
data governance becomes a function
of the entire end-to-end pipeline.
Behind the scenes,
governance functions such as
data privacy, data quality,
data cataloging are required
to deliver a comprehensive data governance
for an AI application.
Okay, so, that was the first part
of how data personalities
can make the most, right?
Have a macro-vision
of what it means to the data pipeline.
The next aspect is a little
bit more prescriptive approach,
like taking a deeper look
into how to make the most of
the AI-ready data foundation.
And that is about leveraging
the enhanced capabilities
of that foundation
to drive AI developer
and end user experience.
And we thought it best to cover
with an example agentic AI
travel reservation application,
just like I promised Shikha.
All right,
this is an airlines reservation
agentic AI demo application
that we have built.
I asked the agent to show
me all available flights
from JFK, New York to
Los Angeles, California.
The agent starts thinking
about it and goes to work.
For the purpose of this demo,
you will see, we are also
printing diagnostic information.
So, that tells us what
the agent is calling,
what it's doing and for what purpose.
So, we give it a few seconds
for the agent to do its job.
And then, we can see very soon
that the agent will return
several flight options for me.
And those options will include things,
like flight schedules
for different airlines,
it will show me the ticket
pricing again by each airline.
In this case, it was talking
to a third-party travel agency.
It'll show me user reviews
from my colleagues in my organization
that have flown the same
airline in the recent past.
So, like that gives me a
well-rounded, well-informed way
of choosing the flight that
I want to use over here.
It's also telling me
that based on my company travel policies,
there are certain cases
where I might need an exception
to book that flight, right?
I mean, we at Amazon, have that policy.
I'm hoping most organizations
have something similar
that they can relate to,
is when making a choice
that doesn't align with a company policy,
you have to work through
an exception process.
So, that's what's happening over here.
And then, finally,
the agent is also making recommendations
that are actually policy-compliant
and factors in my travel preferences.
So, this is the first
part of the demo, right,
getting all that information.
Now, we are calling this scenario one,
because there is a scenario two.
This is where I feel I
don't want to get in trouble
with my manager, right?
I mean, I don't need to get an exception.
And I go ahead
and I ask the agent to book
the American Airlines flight.
I know that is compliant,
looking at the pricing aspect
that it's showed me earlier,
it works with the company policy.
And timing-wise, let's say for
now, it works for me as well.
Again, the agent's thinking
starts going to work.
Similar to previous part,
we are printing some
diagnostic information
that we will come back to later.
The agent confirms the reservation.
It uses my travel preferences
such as my meal type,
the kind of seats I prefer,
whether a window seat or an aisle seat,
what kind of person I am
and performs a few backend operations,
like emailing me the e-ticket and stuff.
Okay, so, that was a demo.
And for the purpose of
the rest of this talk,
we will use this reference architecture
of the airlines demo
to help us work through what's
happening behind the scenes.
The user prompts,
interacts with the agent,
which in turn then works with
a list of tools or API calls
that integrate with
different types of sources,
like the third-party travel agency
that makes flight data available,
the user's internal corporate
data warehouse and data lake,
which is on Amazon Redshift and S3
and a booking action with a third-party.
There are a few operational
transactions happening
behind the scenes
that we will cover when we
talk about multiple agents.
So, just for context,
this is a demo
that we whitecoded using
Kiro and Strands Agents.
People, you're familiar with
Kiro and Strands Agents?
- [Audience Member 4] Yes.
- Nice.
For those, who aren't, Kiro is AWS' AI IDE
that turns prompts into
specs and then into code.
It's actually pretty cool.
And then, Strands Agents
is an open-source SDK
that takes a model-driven
approach to building AI agents.
Strands supports all LLMs.
I suspect most of us
have our favorite model.
Mine is Claude Sonnet
and that is what we are using over here.
There you go.
All right, before we jump
into the details of the application,
I want to take a slight detour over here
to position what is generally
called an agentic loop,
or a ReAct loop.
In terms of the transaction workflow
between the agent and the
tool and the model or the LLM,
one may think that the
flow is more or less linear
as in the user prompt invokes the agent,
which in turn, executes the tool API
and then, returns the results to the agent
and then, returns the final
response to the prompt.
Well, not really.
At the center of an agentic
AI application is a loop.
When the user instructs the system
to complete a task or a transaction,
the workflow enters an event loop
where it iterates until it
considers the task completed,
or the question answered.
This design pattern is typically
called the Reason plus Act,
or the ReAct loop
and is the most popular design pattern
for agentic AI applications.
This is how we are illustrating it.
This basic architecture allows
an agentic AI application
to accomplish tasks over the course
of multiple event loop iterations.
Now, while on one hand,
this event loop means a more meaningful
and relevant response to the user,
however, on the other hand,
it also means a slower
and less efficient agent.
It also means an unpredictable number
of model invocations consuming
an uncontrolled amount
of input and output tokens
that impact both cost and performance.
A good data foundation can help
with minimizing that impact,
starting with the AWS data
and analytics MCP servers.
Coming back to the reference
architecture of our agent demo,
let's look at the tools that we are using.
These are either hardcoded
API calls or function calls
that you can pass as tools
to the agent to invoke.
What this means,
is that the agent's capabilities
are fixed at design time.
It doesn't really have
a choice or the ability
to reason or plan which
tool to use to call,
depending on the task.
You are limiting its capabilities
and all the queries that
it is using also need
to be predefined for the usage over here.
This is where MCP servers bring value.
You let the model figure out
what it needs through natural language.
It also replaces the heavy-lifting
of managing multiple API SDKs and formats,
which I can imagine is a
production nightmare to most.
MCPs enable true agent autonomy,
the ability to iteratively
call tools, get results
and decide the next steps in a ReAct loop.
Just a little bit of
overview on MCP servers.
They don't really replace APIs.
They add a conversational
layer to the LLM.
They act as a universal language,
eliminating the need for
custom integration layers
between different AI models and tools.
Too much structured data with
traditional API calls tends
to confuse the agent.
I do want to point out over here
that MCP servers are not
always a one-size-fit-all.
There are operations
that are better served
through traditional API calls.
For example, the
MCP-driven agents struggle
with large-scale data
processing with structured data
and complex data transformations even,
such as the get flight details function
that you saw earlier over there.
We did not convert that into MCP,
we didn't have an MCP server for it.
But regardless, a direct API
call serves a better purpose
for those kinds of transactions.
Similarly, operations
that require deterministic
and time-sensitive outcomes,
like the booking a reservation,
right, that function call,
that is also a better fit
for a direct API call,
instead of an MCP server call.
It's very easy for these operations,
the kinds that we just discussed
to exceed the LLMs' context windows
and drive up costs and latency.
In our demo, we used the Redshift
and S3 Tables MCP servers.
The Redshift MCP server acts as a bridge
between your Redshift
clients sitting on the agent
and your Amazon Redshift infrastructure.
It does natural language transformations.
And among other things,
it automatically discovers
your Redshift clusters,
whether it's provisioned or serverless,
can work across multiple clusters,
browse databases, schemas,
tables and columns
through natural language
and execute SQL queries in read-only mode,
which provides you with
built-in safety protections.
Likewise, with the Amazon
S3 Tables MCP server,
you can interact with tabular datasets,
using natural language.
You can list and create S3 Table buckets,
namespace and tables.
You can also query and
commit data to an S3 table
through this MCP server.
The AWS MCP server repository is a suite
of specialized MCP servers.
And we invite you
to check out all the publicly
available MCP servers
that can help you make your
agentic AI applications,
more autonomous and less expensive.
Moving on from MCP servers
to context management,
another area where data personalities,
like data engineers, data analysts,
data scientists can leverage
the AI-ready data foundation
on AWS.
We touched a little bit on context
when we discussed the ReAct agentic loop.
A simple way to think about
context here is to think of it
as the working memory of
the model, of the LLM,
the memory that lets it interpret, reason
and then take action for
the best outcome possible.
Let's look at that in a
little bit more detail.
So, while AI agents get
sophisticated reasoning capabilities
from models and LLMs,
they face two key limitations.
One, LLMs are stateless
and unable to remember past interactions,
or maintain context.
And two, the finite or
limited context window
that LLMs have,
restricts the amount of
data that they can hold
and use it to process at each step.
Now, the kind of data
that the model typically keeps
within the context window
involves three core areas.
First is the instruction set, right,
instructions such as the
user and system prompts,
the state of the conversation
session that you're having,
conversation history, learned
lessons, user profiles
and so on.
So, that's the kind of
data and information
that sits in that instruction set.
The second area is the knowledge base.
So, knowledge bases are,
again, think of it like
centralized repositories
of structured and unstructured data.
This is information that serves
as grounding data for AI.
They can include things,
like documents, FAQs,
product specifications,
best practices from your organization.
In our demo,
we are using the company
travel policy documents
as the knowledge base
and we look at it
in a little bit more deep
in this, very quickly.
This is where the agent can tell me,
which tickets are within
the company travel policy
and which are not.
And then we have data coming
from the tools or the MCP
servers that we just saw.
In this demo, we bring the
airline reviews from S3 Tables.
These are reviews by my colleagues
that were posted into that knowledge base
that we use make decisions.
So, the model needs to work
with a lot of current
and fresh information
within its limited context window
to be able to advise me on
the right course of action.
This is where context management,
or context engineering comes into play.
This working memory as
defined by a context window,
is a length of the maximum amount
of input data it can hold
or consider or remember
at any point in time.
And here's the kicker for that.
Context windows are finite
and tokens are expensive.
We saw earlier how MCP
servers are designed
to be more context-efficient
and less verbose than traditional APIs.
So, next, we will look at how best
to manage the limited and
expensive context window
with the help of agentic
memory and vector stores.
All right, so, let's
quickly refresh our memory
from the parts of the demo
where the agent is retrieving
and memorizing several data points,
including flight availability information,
my booking reservation
and my travel preferences.
So, this is the agentic memory
in play, in action over here.
Here, for this function,
what we are doing,
is we're using the
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore
to serve the purpose of agentic memory.
AgentCore, some of you might know this,
it's a modular service
that provides you
everything you need to go
with agents, up to production,
including observability.
In our example,
we are using it to deliver
personalized experiences
with persistent memory stored
in this particular service.
It supports most of the popular
frameworks and protocols,
like the Strands Agents
and the MCP servers that we saw earlier
that we are using for our demo.
And then, depending on the nature
of your agentic application
and the business case,
if you're a shop that
needs an over-the-shelf,
or off-the-shelf kind of solution,
like Bedrock AgentCore is
a good choice over there,
or if you're an organization
that needs to build something custom,
something more specific to your needs,
AWS has several other options
that agents can use to
build their agentic memory.
These include things like
ElastiCache for Valkey
and in-memory, high-performance,
key-value datastore.
We also have DynamoDB or
distributed NoSQL database,
Neptune Analytics
for knowledge, graph-based
dynamic relationships
and several others.
So, the agent can retain knowledge
to learn and problem-solve.
It can deliver contextual intelligence
through pattern recognition
and personalized interactions
by remembering preferences
and past conversations.
The next important piece
of context management is
knowledge bases, right?
This is where unstructured
data comes into the front.
In our demo,
we are using the company's
travel policy documents,
such as PDF, HTML files scraped through
to build a knowledge base on Amazon S3.
And then, we are using Amazon
OpenSearch as a vector store
to do a semantic search
to apply the correct
policy to the booking.
Again, like we did previously,
let's refresh our memory
on the information
that our agent is using
from the knowledge base
to apply the relevant travel policy.
We see a pricing policy
around lower and upper bounds
that was retrieved from
the vector database
to add to the context window.
In this case, our agent is
using the knowledge bases
for Amazon Bedrock service
to perform this function.
Now, the way this is
working behind the scenes,
this service provides the
end-to-end RAG workflow for us.
You simply specify the
location of your data,
which, in this case, is S3.
It selects an embedding model
to convert that data
into vector embeddings.
And then have the service
point to a vector store,
which, in our case, is Amazon OpenSearch
to create that vector index.
Our agent fetches that context
and adds it to the context
window in the model,
so, for the model to be able to reason
and use that information in
the most appropriate way.
A little bit about vector
engine for Amazon OpenSearch,
it's a search service,
delivers highly relevant
and accurate responses
and provides the vector indexes of scales
that are production-ready.
And at this "re:Invent",
we are introducing the
general availability
of GPU acceleration for the
OpenSearch vector engine.
By offloading vector search
computations to GPUs,
OpenSearch can achieve up to 10 times
on speed and compute costs,
which is great
for applications like RAG,
Retrieval-Augmented Generation
and recommendation systems.
And similarly, just like
AWS for agentic memory,
depending on your use case
and your business needs,
AWS provides additional choices
for deploying a vector store
for your AI application,
including the general availability
of Amazon S3 Vectors
announced at this "re:Invent"
for cost-effective,
large-scale vector processing,
or vector storage.
Okay, besides personalized responses,
another area of context management,
is to have a timely response.
A travel reservation agentic
AI application is expected
to maintain the latest information
of the user's travel preferences
as they can change over time.
This is where Change Data
Capture, CDC events combined
with streaming ingestion, storage
and near real-time processing
provide current information
to the AI application's knowledge base.
Also, depending on the use
case and business needs,
AWS has several streaming and
CDC options to choose from,
including Amazon Kinesis
Data Streams, AWS Glue,
Amazon Managed Apache Flink
for real-time aggregations.
Moving on to the next aspect
of leveraging your AI-ready
data foundation on AWS,
let's talk about
event-driven architectures
in scenarios where you
have multiple agents
that are providing an agentic AI function.
Multiple agents is where an agent needs
to gather information
from multiple sources,
including other agents, tools and systems.
And this is a very likely
scenario in production
when you build an agentic AI application
where you end up with multiple AI agents.
Multiple agents, a good
way to think about those,
is like a loosely coupled
asynchronous architecture
that is very similar to a
microservices-based application
where multiple agents work independently,
but at the same time, in
collaboration with each other,
moving data and events,
making sure unavailability of
one does not affect the other.
This is scenario two
where let's say I want to book a flight,
which actually violates
the policy exceptions.
So, this will demonstrate
how multiple agents
comes into play, right?
So, as I said, scenario two of the demo
where I am having to book a ticket
that is outside of my company policy,
but works better for my
availability schedule.
As expected, it comes back to tell me
that this particular flight
will need my manager approval.
And as part of backend
operation, what I'm doing,
I request and get the
approval from my manager
and then we'll wait for the agent,
it's doing a little bit of
a hard-thinking over here,
it's a policy exception,
so, there it goes.
So, now, the agent is telling me
that I need an approval from my manager.
Because this choice
of flight is violating my company policy.
Like I mentioned, I get the
approval from my manager
through a backend operation.
And then I tell the agent,
"Yes, I have the approval."
The agent takes that information
and does some validation
and then goes ahead and
books the reservation for me.
As you can see, it's performing
the similar operations
that we saw earlier,
which used components
of the knowledge base,
the agentic memory, my user preferences
and also does a few backend operations.
Let's take a look at those
backend operations, right?
These backend operations are
basically additional agents
that are collaborating
with our main agent.
There's a confirmation
email notification agent,
an agent that triggers a rule
if a company policy on
expenses is satisfied or not
and an agent that logs all transactions
to a backend database.
Now, our main agent could actually be made
to handle all these tasks in one.
But if you recall the ReAct loop, right,
agents can also get easily confused
and you're also working with
the limited context window
and the agentic memory.
So, on the other hand,
having multiple agents,
how does that help?
Multiple agents performing
a unit or a single task,
are easier to build
and you can build in resiliency
with an event-driven architecture, right?
This is something that looks
like this over here for us.
Using a service like
Amazon Managed Streaming
for Apache Kafka or Amazon MSK,
which is a fully managed
Apache Kafka setup,
you can loosely couple all the agents,
while ensuring real-time
exchange for low latency
with built-in scalability
where there is a need to add
more agents, for example,
and manage persistent events
with Multi-AZ deployments
and automated recovery.
An event-driven multiple architecture,
not only decouples and
scales the agent task,
it also provides a distributed
processing platform
for the agentic AI application
with durable messages
and delivery guarantees
as provided with the MSK service.
A little bit about the Amazon MSK service.
It can process high-throughput events,
enabling agents to respond
to various patterns
and real-time scenario changes.
Asynchronous communication
in Amazon MSK facilitated
by event-driven architectures
provides benefits,
such as decoupling, independent scaling
and improving fall tolerance
through replication.
And now, I would like to
invite Shikha back to us
to tell us how data readiness can be made,
can be worked upon through
the AI-ready data foundation.
Shikha?
- Thank you, Taz.
How are we doing?
That was a lot to consume, right?
Good, good?
All right, I think Taz did
what he told me that he was gonna do.
He was like, "Okay, I will use
our data to create agents."
And he created multiple agents.
As we were getting ready for the session,
we purposefully wanted
to do more of a show,
rather than tell.
So, I hope it's working for you.
Quick raise of hands if
it's working for you.
Yeah?
Okay, cool, cool, cool.
So, who believes in this?
Does this make sense to you guys, yeah?
So, just like how humans
need maps, AI needs metadata.
So, how does this fit
into our overall picture
of what we have seen so far?
So, we saw Taz use a lot of
data and built-in context.
We talked about context management
and how context comes in
through knowledge bases
and through session logs
and through data that is coming
through tools or databases.
Is metadata new, guys,
like how many of you
have dealt with metadata
for like decades now, right?
It's not new, but it is cool now.
So, I think,
metadata is definitely
having a moment right now.
And I think, it's great.
Because all of the context
that we are talking about
is essentially metadata
and data that is sitting
in unstructured files,
like Taz pointed out the policy file.
We are gonna go through more
of the traditional data side of readiness,
which is data sitting in your
data warehouses, data lakes.
And how do you get that ready
for consumption by our AI agents?
Because that is where all of
our data is sitting right now,
right?
So, when Taz and I started
thinking about our session,
we were like,
"Well, all of our data is
like literally all over.
And it's not even in AWS,
some of it is outside.
How do we bring it all together?"
So, if everybody accepts this,
then, I think we are gonna go
into the next side of the story.
So, we have our data sources, right?
Traditionally, we've had
data warehouses, data lakes,
then came the lakehouses,
then all these different data sources
where data is just sprawling.
All of that comes together
through the architecture
that Taz is pointing out
with generating more and
more metadata, right?
So, we generate metadata
as we enrich each of these
datasets with more information.
We generate metadata on data
quality and data lineage
as we get this all data moved into a form
where our agents can use
it and humans can use it.
So, metadata is definitely having a moment
and I would highly encourage
everybody to think of this
as a key foundation that
you have to invest in
for your AI initiatives.
So, what does really
metadata help us do, right?
So, I don't think this
story will be very new,
but again, I'm gonna emphasize
that it's what we used to
do for humans is a must now
for AI agents.
Because AI agents are not
gonna call their friend, right?
Like we want autonomous
agents working on our data
and on the context that
we are providing them.
So, it becomes more and more useful for us
to bake metadata into our systems.
So, let me just talk about
this cycle for a second.
So, in most companies
and I'm assuming that this
will sound familiar to you,
there's data producers,
people who create the data or own the data
and there's data consumers,
which now is getting filled
up a lot with not just humans,
but also AI, right?
Does this sound familiar to you, guys?
- [Audience Member 5] Yes.
- Yeah?
It's very much the story
that we've been living with.
But then it's now vital
for us to have the context,
because AI cannot work
without the context, right?
So, we gotta make sure
that we are building the
right technology in the middle
to bring these things together, right,
to add the right context
in terms of metadata,
to have the right frameworks
in terms of governance,
so that humans and AI
can use the same systems
that we have been using
by adding the right components to it.
Does this make sense?
Quick show of hands, okay, cool.
All right, so, let's go ahead.
How many of you have
heard of Amazon SageMaker?
Yeah?
So, we invested a ton in this platform
in the last few years.
And for those of you
familiar with SageMaker AI,
which used to be the traditional
machine-learning side
of our offering,
we really expanded that
brand and portfolio
to include all of our data analytics
and AI capabilities into it.
So, that is what Amazon SageMaker is.
It's really the center for
all your data analytics AI.
Because we saw this thing coming.
We're like, "Okay, we are gonna need
to bring it all together, right?
Because we can't have these
agents running a havoc
through your ecosystem."
So, what Amazon SageMaker is built on,
is a foundation of the lakehouse,
which is if you're Iceberg-compliant,
you're gonna, this is gonna
be music to your ears,
because anything that is
Iceberg-compliant can come
into this ecosystem
and can bubbled up through
SageMaker's capabilities
of data and AI governance as
well as the Unified Studio,
which brings all of these
capabilities together.
So, next set, couple of demos
that Taz and I gonna show you,
are really using these capabilities
to build the context and the metadata
for your users and your AI first.
And then use that context
to create an application quickly, right?
So, we are going a little
bit behind the scenes here
where Taz really showed you
almost the front-end application
of the agent
and the customer using it
built-in to book a flight.
Now, we are gonna go a
little bit in the backend
and show you just how this gets done.
All right, so, at the center
of that SageMaker picture,
you saw a data and AI governance, right?
So, what does that really mean?
This is the center for where
all of your data, your models,
your agents come together
for availability across your
entire organization, right?
So, I'm assuming, most people
here are data engineers,
software engineers, data platform owners,
that sort of demographic.
Is that right?
Can I, yeah?
Okay, cool.
So, you guys deal with this, right?
So, what SageMaker
really allows you to do,
is bring all of that together.
Then you build trust in it.
So, we talked about data
quality and data lineage.
Again, words that are not really new,
but are of immense
importance in this new world.
Because we gotta get this right,
so that the context is all built-in
into our data and metadata.
And then, applying the right guardrails
around who can use this data?
You don't want your notify
agent using your policy data,
you don't want your, like
it's the whole picture,
like in humans,
you can call and make the
right controls happen.
But in agents,
it's all the more important
to set the right guardrails
and the right workflows
in the system itself.
All of that, of course, is
very transparent and auditable.
So, all of the metadata that
gets generated through this,
for example, at the asset level goes back
into S3 Tables, right?
So, what does that mean?
That your agents can go read
that data directly, right?
So, if I put all the metadata
that I'm creating through
SageMaker back into S3 Tables,
you can read that data,
your agents can read that data
and infer information from it
without having to go
through the whole stack.
All right,
so two key important things,
again, takeaways, right?
So, for data and AI
initiatives in general, right,
like you want to apply the same framework
across your data, models
and all kinds of assets.
And you wanna invest in metadata,
as well as a comprehensive
data governance around it.
All right, let me show
you some stuff in action.
So, we talked a lot about metadata.
Metadata is not easily
available for the things
that we've had for
many, many years, right?
Not every system that we own,
has useful business context
attached to it, it doesn't.
The tables are hard to tell.
For those of you who are in the SAP land,
like the table name doesn't tell you much,
it's things like that, right?
So, what we need to do is
really add the right metadata
to all of our tables as well as columns.
But we can't expect humans
to be creating that, right?
So, what I wanna show you
here is for one of the tables
that Taz showed you in the demo,
we go and create metadata
automatically through AI.
So, again, with SageMaker,
what we have tried to do is
we are building the system
for you to use for your AI initiatives.
But we have also built
enough AI into the system
to make the system more productive, right?
So, in this particular case,
I'm picking the customer_reviews table.
You can see
that there is a quick generate
description button up here.
It's showing me the
typical technical metadata
that is readily available usually
and I can add to it.
I can see the schema of
the table that I have,
it shows some data quality,
we'll get to that in a minute.
But I want some more useful
business context added to it,
so that I can feed it to my
humans as well as AI, right?
So, it's gonna think a
minute, it's doing it live.
We didn't wanna shorten
this stuff for you,
so that you know that
it does take a minute.
But as you can see while it's loading,
like on the rest of the screen,
you have glossary terms, metadata forms,
which you can add additional ones.
And there you go, the
metadata is generated.
So, here, I have an option to
edit the metadata if I want.
But I've seen pretty good success,
so I'm just gonna accept it.
And you can see that in the summary,
it's giving some very helpful pointers.
So, what does this data have?
What can it be used for, right?
Things that we would be
like wanting somebody
to put in the data,
so that we can query this information,
we can use this information
when you're trying to use it.
And it just generates all of
that in automatically, right?
That's the power of LLMs
that we are getting the
benefit of right now.
It also went to the column level
and generated descriptions there too.
So, earlier, if you remember
when we came to the schema,
it was largely empty.
But now, you can see
that there's even column-level
descriptions added.
And I am accepting all of the
descriptions here as well,
because I think they're
pretty recent for my use here.
The other things you see on this screen,
are there is a data quality scores
that are available as well, right?
So, this got pulled in
by looking at the rules
that I had set for this
table back in Glue,
which is how I brought it, right?
So, those table, that is pulled in.
I have a clear understanding here
that "Okay, this data is only 60% good,
you'd really wanna use it?"
But you wanna at least show
that to your users upfront,
so that they know what
they're getting into, right,
and they're not being misled.
Now, the lineage story here,
(Shikha laughs)
Taz and I were laughing that
it just shows one table,
because we didn't combine it
with a bunch of other things.
But if you bring a bunch
of things together,
it shows you a beautiful graph
of how this data was constructed.
Anyways, now that I have
put all that information,
I publish that asset back
into SageMaker Catalog.
So, now, it becomes readily available
for another user to come in,
who's coming in right now
and they search for customer
reviews and that table appears.
So, now, another user from
another side of the world,
or another agent can come
in and search your catalog
for using this information
by some keywords.
And if I like it, you can subscribe to it,
which means that you're
getting the actual grants
to use this data for your systems,
which is again, like
something that is audited,
you can query it, you know
who's using what data.
So, again, pretty useful.
Really quick demo on the behind the scenes
of how this data got ready for Taz to use.
So, in this area,
we are really introducing
a lot of capabilities.
Some of you may be familiar but maybe new.
So, I'm just gonna
quickly go through that.
But metadata, in general, is
getting a lot of investment
across AWS.
You'll see that we are
adding metadata capabilities
at the storage layer at S3.
I'm gonna call out some
of the key capabilities
that we have added to SageMaker Catalog,
which is really at column level.
You can have enhanced descriptions,
you can have metadata forms,
gives you so much more control
over what kind of context do
you want added to your data,
so that your agents
and your humans have all the
information available, right?
You can also enforce that, right?
So, you can now say
that "For this use case,
this particular table or
column is not usable."
That also gives you that feature
with the enforcement of metadata forms,
as well as glossaries.
Because you can spell that
out a lot more clearly
when the context is added to your data.
Also, again, it's really hard
to create these things
from scratch, right?
So, we are continuing to
invest in our automation
where we gave the automated
business subscriptions first
and now, we are also
giving the capabilities
to add business glossaries automatically.
They'll give you suggestions,
you can accept them,
or you can associate them
with a pre-existing glossary.
It just become super easy.
And then, like I mentioned earlier,
we are putting that all
back into S3, right?
So, then, it's available
at even your storage layer,
the metadata itself is available
for you to query and use with your agents.
How many folks here have
data outside of AWS?
Most of you, right?
Yeah, even I do.
(Shikha giggles)
So, very excited for this
particular capability,
which is if you are, again,
if you subscribe to
Iceberg, this is great.
We are investing a ton in Iceberg.
This is catalog federation
to external Apache Iceberg Catalogs.
So, for example, if you use
Databricks or Snowflake,
you can bring in, read those tables
from these third-party solutions
and you can bring them
into Glue Data Catalog,
so that it becomes available
in the same SageMaker ecosystem
that I showed you earlier, right?
So, you can, for example, bring
in a table from Databricks,
you can catalog it,
you can add the automated
business descriptions to it,
you can do all of that
from within SageMaker
if you're leveraging this capability.
Super excited about this one!
This has been a huge ask
from most of our customers!
All right.
Now that we have all
of that data together,
so, now, our data engineer,
data scientist, Taz wants
to build something on
all of that data, right?
So, how do you do that quickly
without having to now build
like the traditional pipelines,
or go to five different
tools to do your things?
So, if you're familiar with
SageMaker Unified Studio,
we are adding a ton here.
We have actually in the
last couple of weeks.
So, one is one-click onboarding
of existing datasets.
What this means,
is if your data is part
of Glue Data Catalog,
or you just did the external federation
from Databricks or Snowflake,
with a single click of that,
that data can be made available
in SageMaker Unified Studio.
What that means there,
is there is also a net new notebook there
that we have added, which is pretty cool.
I would encourage you guys to try out.
Taz is gonna come show
that to us in a minute.
But this is a polyglot notebook.
So, you can have cells with
SQL, cells with Python,
they can correlate
and it has a built-in data agent in it,
which, again, Taz used to help
create the little application
that we did, which we'll just show you,
which is really, really cool, guys,
like it can create code of
all types automatically.
We'll show you in a second.
It can also correct
coding errors within it.
So, if you guys are playing with,
how many folks here are familiar
with like Cursor or Windsurf or Lovable,
or that breed of things?
Yeah, so, I think you'll love it
if you dabbled in that space.
Because there is a lot of
good stuff here that you can,
it saves a ton of time.
I was playing with an
application last week
and literally, like, it
created the code for me.
And then, I'm like
"What the heck is this?"
(Shikha giggles)
And then, there was an error
and I did the click fix with AI,
it fixed the code for me.
We are actually gonna show you that live
in a second as well.
So, Taz, do you wanna come back
and show us how this works?
- Absolutely!
Well, if you haven't realized
so far, I'm the demo guy.
(Shikha laughs)
Okay, I know we threw,
we showed a lot of demos
and this is the last one we promise.
But this is the coolest one.
And you can see how excited
I'm, right, with this.
So, you earlier saw Shikha talk
about data agent, data notebook.
And what I want to show here,
is the customer user review data.
How easy it is to do a
subjective analysis of that data.
Anyone here tried ever
to do a sentiment analysis of a dataset
that is human-dependent?
I mean, you can imagine the number
of machine-learning libraries
that you have to use
to get the code right and
actually get the right results.
To me, I can imagine it can
take me about two weeks of time.
This demo took less than 10 minutes.
Let me stop talking about
that, let me start the demo.
It's a little long, but pay attention.
I think I can promise you
that you'll enjoy this.
All right, so, we are starting
with the launching the
IAM-based SageMaker interface
and quickly navigating
to our customer review dataset, right?
And then, we create a data notebook just
by the click of a button,
pre-configured with a
cell that is telling me
what my dataset is
and a simple SQL query,
so I can make sure I have
the right permissions
to my dataset
and I'm looking at the right
data in the right context.
I go ahead and run that query
and confirm I have the right dataset.
So, keep in mind, this is
the customer user review data
that we are using in our agentic AI demo.
On the right side of the data
notebook is the data agent
that Shikha was talking about earlier.
I want to test this data agent, right?
I want to put it through a grind
to see how good it is, right?
And this is what we are
going to do over here.
I start with giving it
something very simple by saying,
"Give me the count of unique
flights with reviews," right?
I also intentionally use bad grammar
to see is it picking up my intent,
what I'm really trying to find?
(audience member coughing)
It goes ahead, spins up a cell,
it decides to use SQL on its own.
And I run that query
and yes, that is essentially
what I had in mind,
what I was looking for.
It gave me that data.
Okay, so, that was simple, right?
I want to test it with
something more challenging.
So, I come up with something over here.
I give the agent a complex task
to do a subjective analysis
of the customer reviews
by asking it to do a sentiment analysis
of the data that I have.
So, this is where I want to see,
"Do I really have confidence
in my user reviews," right?
How's the distribution of
positive versus negative?
What does that look like?
So, I go ahead, you can see,
I'm asking it very nicely.
"Can you do a sentiment analysis
for the reviews of my data?"
The agent goes into thinking mode
and then comes back with an
execution plan over here.
Waiting on it.
There you go.
So, what it's doing is
it automatically decided
to switch from SQL to
Python for this task.
I don't have to tell it anything.
It determines the Python
libraries that are needed
and available for this task
in my notebook environment.
For example, it plans to use,
and I know it's a little hard to see,
but take my word for it,
it's trying to use the TextBlob library
to process textual data
and the Transformers library
that it found in my environment
for natural language processing
using pre-trained models
for that sentiment analysis
that I was asking about it.
And in this case, it decided
to use the DistilBERT model,
that is ideal for a sentiment analysis
in notebook-style environments.
All right?
And then, the agent tries
to show off actually
by also proposing a visualization summary
of the sentiment analysis,
followed by a breakdown of the flight
with the most positive reviews.
We run the first cell over here.
And as you can see, it is now
working on the dependencies,
it is thinking through it.
Let's see what it comes back with.
All right, it came back
with an error over here.
This error is essentially
what it's telling us,
the DataFrame that was passed to this cell
from the previous SQL query is not right.
Being who I am, a little bit lazy,
I know what's wrong, I'm just
don't wanna fix it myself.
I use the fix with AI feature
that we have in this notebook.
There you go.
- [Shikha Verma] And folks,
as it is fixing with the AI,
I know we are coming up at time.
So, we tried something
different here for this session.
We did more show than tell.
If this worked for you,
please do give us feedback
in the session survey.
'Cause we'd like to do more of
this if this worked for you.
So, while that is fixing with AI,
here's a human announcement for you.
- Right, it did its job, Shikha.
Thank you for that.
And all right, it fixed it,
it made the code change.
And now, it is telling me,
"Okay, I've made that change.
I think this will work.
If you like it, accept and run."
I do that.
Okay, as in the real world,
another error, right?
And this time, it's a
little bit more challenging,
what that error is.
It's talking about a Keras library
that is not compatible with
what it's trying to do.
And the Python code is telling me,
"Go ahead and install this
to make it compatible."
Again, okay, now I want
to test the fix with AI a little bit more.
I tell it, "Why don't you try to fix it?"
So, this is what the agent does,
the data agent does, right?
It looks at the error
and it knows that there's
a compatibility issue,
but it takes a different
direction in fixing that error.
So, instead of fixing
the compatibility issue,
it actually pivots to a
different library like PyTorch,
because it knows that will work for sure.
Because that's the response
that it is giving me.
You can see it's made the
code change line number eight.
And again, like I said, the
agent was actually showing off.
It made the change in the comment as well,
that "I'm changing this
library to PyTorch."
All right, I accept it, I run it.
It's running the code,
it's running the cell.
All right, I got one output that it cannot
and I got the results of
what it was trying to do.
Okay, so, that was the first cell
where it was doing the
analysis for the sentiment.
Next, it's going to do a graphing
of the results over here.
Again, it generated the
Python code on its own.
It's using Matplot libraries by itself.
I simply go ahead, run it.
This one runs without any issues.
I got my data.
I go from data engineer,
to data scientists,
to a data analyst, all in one over here.
All right?
And then the last query,
which is essentially
giving me the highest count
of the best airline with
the most positive reviews.
In the interest of time,
I'm just gonna move on to the next slide,
which is the second-last slide over here.
Key takeaways, not gonna read this slide.
We talked a lot about this over here.
Key idea is you don't really
have to build anything new
in terms of data foundation.
AWS has what it takes for you
to build your agentic AI applications.
Leverage the critical path
between data and AI through
purpose-built capabilities,
some of which we saw over here today,
MCP servers, context management,
vector stores and data governance.
And with that, folks,
if you have additional needs,
we do have programs to
help you get started.
Thank you for-
- Thank you.
- [Imtiaz Sayed] Your
patience staying with us.
I appreciate that.
(audience applauding)